aquí tenemos una variable binomial x y
la voy a definir de la siguiente manera
la voy a definir como el número de
éxitos después de n ejecuciones déjenme
notar eso
el número de éxitos después de n
ejecuciones donde la probabilidad de
éxito para cada ejecución independiente
es p déjame ponerlo también
donde la probabilidad de éxito para cada
ejecución independiente es p y creo que
esta es una forma razonable de describir
cualquier variable binomial donde
suponemos que cada una de estas
ejecuciones son independientes la
probabilidad es constante es siempre p
tenemos un número fijo de ejecuciones n
y el resultado de cada ejecución puede
ser un éxito o un fracaso pero en este
vídeo nos vamos a enfocar en cuál será
el valor esperado de esta variable
binomial x es decir vamos a buscar
cuánto es el valor esperado de esta
variable binomial x y esta vez voy a
quitar la atención y te voy a dar la
respuesta posteriormente en este vídeo
vamos a demostrar por qué es así el
valor esperado de esta variable binomial
x será igual al número de ejecuciones
por la probabilidad de éxito de cada una
de estas ejecuciones n por pep así que
imaginemos un escenario voy a decir que
en este escenario cada ejecución es un
tiro penal déjame escribirlo ok vamos a
hablar de fútbol y como estamos hablando
de fútbol éxito es meter gol entonces
déjame escribirlo donde éxito es anotar
un gol y vamos a decir que la
probabilidad de meter gol es de p
es decir p es el porcentaje de tiros
penales que terminan en gol
voy a suponer que es igual al 30% ok
hola podemos ver como un 0.3 de lujo y
también supongamos que vamos a tirar 10
penales
entonces n va a ser igual am
10 y espero que esto te dé una idea más
concreta así que en este escenario
particular el valor esperado de x va a
ser igual y bueno es el número de goles
después de tirar estos 10 penales cuando
un porcentaje de gol por tiro penal del
30 por ciento basándonos en lo que acabo
de escribir acá arriba bueno esto será n
por pep es decir el número de
ejecuciones que ya vimos es 10 y estos
multiplicarlo por la probabilidad de
meter goles en una ejecución que como
vimos es 0.3 y 10 por 0.3 bueno eso es
muy fácil es 3 parece bastante natural
pensar que se esperan 3 goles ahora para
estar completamente seguros que esto es
cierto qué te parece si lo demostramos
usando algunas propiedades del valor
esperado
en particular voy a pensar en la
propiedad que dice que el valor esperado
de la suma de dos variables aleatorias
independientes
supongamos x y james
esto va a ser igual al valor esperado de
la primera de ellas ok
más el valor esperado de la segunda de
ellas
y esta propiedad es muy importante y ya
la hemos visto en otros vídeos así que
suponiendo esta propiedad qué te parece
si construimos una nueva variable
aleatoria ya esta nueva variable
aleatoria le voy a poner el nombre de
james y sabemos algunas cosas de esta
nueva variable y sabemos que la
probabilidad de que que sea igual a 1 va
a hacer de bueno voy a decir que es p ok
y la probabilidad de que james sea igual
a cero voy a decir que es bueno
1 - p
1 - p ok y estas dos son las únicas
posibles salidas para esta variable
aleatoria de modo que ya puedes ver a
dónde vamos porque puedes pensar que
esta variable aleatoria solo te da una
ejecución donde obtienes uno si tienes
éxito o cero si fracasas por lo tanto
puedes ver a nuestra variable aleatoria
original déjame ponerlo aquí nuestra
variable aleatoria original x como g
más
[Aplausos]
más y así me voy a mantener sumando y es
tantas como en veces porque tenemos en
ejecución es entonces déjame ponerlo
aquí tengo en 10 en 10
de manera específica en este ejemplo en
particular puedes pensar que obtienes
uno si metes un gol o cero si fallas el
penal y entonces tienes diez ejecuciones
que representa el resultado de cada
ejecución y puedes ver a x como la suma
de estas n ejecuciones y lo que
realmente queremos hacer es demostrar
esta igualdad bien entonces veamos acá
abajo tomemos el valor esperado de ambos
lados así que obtengo lo siguiente el
valor esperado de x ok esto va a ser
igual al valor esperado de bueno de todo
esto pero si usamos esta propiedad puedo
escribir lo como el valor esperado de i
más el valor esperado de g
y así me voy a mantener sumando y
sumando y sumando tanto como n veces el
valor esperado de yen y por lo tanto
puedo decir que todas estas de aquí son
n déjame ponerlo todas estás de aquí son
n
así que podemos escribir esto como n
veces el valor esperado de iu y por lo
tanto solo falta saber cuál es el valor
esperado de esta variable y y bueno esto
es muy sencillo lo podemos obtener
directamente de aquí déjame escribirlo
el valor esperado de esta variable que
se obtienen simplemente ponderando los
resultados por su probabilidad y como
solamente tenemos dos posibles
resultados discretos es muy fácil de
calcular va a ser la probabilidad p
déjame ponerla la probabilidad de que
multiplican al primero de los resultados
lo cual es 1
por 1 ya esto le sumamos la probabilidad
de 1
p la probabilidad de 1 - p de obtener el
otro resultado que es 0 entonces la
probabilidad 1 - p de obtener 0 y bueno
esto es muy fácil de aquí me quedan
estos dos se eliminan porque lo estoy
multiplicando por cero y simplemente me
quedan 1 por p lo cual es p y ya está el
valor esperado de y es simplemente p y
es justo lo que queríamos porque ahora
en lugar de esto puedo escribir ahora a
p déjame ponerlo
esto es p y por lo tanto ya llegamos al
resultado que queríamos el valor
esperado de esta variable aleatoria
binomial x va a ser simplemente
que multiplica a p
y es justo a donde queríamos llegar a
demostrar esta igualdad espero que esto
te haga sentir feliz saludos